good evening and welcome to Tucker
Carlson tonight on a Friday last fall a
Democrat called Tony DeLuca got
reelected to the Pennsylvania state
house while dead not just dead inside
like most politicians but actually dead
not breathing and not only did DeLuca
win after having been dead for a full
month but he won in a landslide Tony
DeLuca got more than 85 percent of the
vote
Now by any measure that is embarrassing
Pennsylvania Democrats elected a dead
man they knew they were doing it they
did it anyway
this would seem to defeat the idea of
representative democracy which is that
you vote for people so they can
represent you
but Party leaders in Pennsylvania were
not embarrassed they were proud quote
well we're incredibly saddened by the
loss of Representative Tony DeLuca they
said in a statement we are proud to see
the voters continue to show their
confidence in him and his commitment to
democratic values by re-electing him
posthumously
in other words electing a guy who can't
possibly represent you is not an offense
against democracy it's the essence of
democracy now it's not a typo they put
that in a press release and actually it
makes it kind of sense when you remember
that it was also in the state of
Pennsylvania the Democratic Party
leaders back to Senate candidate called
John Federman long after he had suffered
a massive stroke and could no longer
talk or communicate clearly
here he is during one of his rare public
appearances last year
you're running for a seat that could
decide the balance of power in
Washington what qualifies you to be a
U.S senator you have 60 Seconds
hi good night everybody if you work full
time you should be able to live in
dignity as well true and I believe they
haven't have any businesses being being
uh you can't have businesses being
subsidized by not paying into
individuals that just simply can't to
pay their own way you're saying tonight
AI that you support fracking that you've
always supported fracking but there is
that 2018 interview that you said quote
I don't support fracking at all so how
do you square the two
oh I I do support fracking and
I don't I don't
I support fracking and I stand and I do
support fracking
now that debate as you well remember was
considered shocking by most everyone who
saw it but not by democrats in
Pennsylvania they didn't seem even
mildly ashamed to be caught running a
candidate who couldn't speak fetterman's
own wife a former illegal alien called
Gisele candidly told reporters how she
deals with her brain damaged husband
quote you just like ignore him when he's
speaking now Democratic voters love this
because they always love it when women
attack and diminish their own husbands
it makes them feel like they're not
alone it's totally normal to hate your
husband and of course they took
giselle's advice and they elected John
fetterman to the Senate
in a party where no debate is allowed
it's not like you need a senator who can
use words or for that matter a president
who can think
now we naively assume that Joe Biden
would be in trouble during the 2020
primaries when he misidentified the
state he was standing in or mistook his
sister for his wife or made about a
hundred other weird and disjointed
statements that suggested regular
amphetamine injections were the only
thing getting him through his rallies
Biden senility seems so obvious and it
was obvious
but what we missed was how much the
Democratic party had changed Joe Biden's
campaign was never about Joe Biden he
could have been anyone dollar sharp
older young alive or dead the candidate
himself was irrelevant What mattered was
the power of the office Democrats just
wanted the seat the details of who
occupied it didn't matter to them
and as if to prove it Dianne Feinstein
has been a senator from California for
more than 30 years she's now 89 the
oldest member of Congress and she is
sadly completely out of it last month
she learned that her staff had announced
her retirement from the Senate she had
no idea watch this
I haven't made that decision I haven't
released anything it will be my plan you
put out the statement
I didn't know they put it out okay
um
so yeah it is what it is
we put out your statement Feinstein
staff informs her we've decided you're
leaving your job and no we didn't tell
you because we don't care what you think
you're just the senator shut up and vote
and Dianne Feinstein just kind of nods
and accepts it
keep in mind this person sits on the
quote intelligence Committee in the
United States Senate
and it's sad really you'd think even a
corrupt machine State like California
would deserve more than this voters
voted for her assuming she would be
aware of their surroundings and maybe
keep their best interests in mind
but no nobody in the party cares because
representative democracy means nothing
to democratic leaders and they don't
mind if you know they feel that way so
that's how Washington actually works but
even by those low standards it has been
a little bracing to watch the short
political career of John fetterman
unfold fetterman got to Washington in
January and within a month suffered a
mental breakdown so severe that he wound
up in the psych ward where he remains
tonight and we're not mocking John
fetterman of course we feel for him
sincerely but the mercenaries in his
orbit very much including his wife
Giselle should be ashamed of what they
have done apparently fetterman cracked
under the strain of a senate campaign in
which he was forced to pretend that the
brain damage he had suffered from a
stroke wasn't actually a big deal no
problem I'm fine
but he was not fine he was so close to
the edge that within weeks of getting to
Washington he wound up in a mental
hospital as an inpatient he has not
appeared in public since
and we're supposed to think that's not a
big deal we're not even supposed to
think about it
and just to show how completely normal
it is for newly elected U.S senators to
have mental breakdowns that disappear
from public view that such
not a big deal that fetterman somehow
just co-sponsored legislation in the U.S
Senate quote U.S senators Bob Casey and
John fetterman of Pennsylvania reads a
straight face news report joined a
bipartisan group of centers on Wednesday
introducing new legislation aimed at
preventing future Freight trained
railments like the one last month in
East Palestine Ohio
so here you have a guy who's getting
around the clock psychiatric care
deciding how to prevent trained
derailments there's so many questions
here but the most obvious one is a
logistical question how is John
fetterman doing this if he's in the
psych ward and we don't know because no
one will say fetterman's Chief of Staff
a man called Adam gentleson is blocking
anyone who dares to ask that question on
social media on Twitter for example
Stephen Miller of the last White House
asked gentles in this quote Adam who is
co-signing and introducing legislation
from Senator fetterman's office well he
himself is currently hospitalized and
under current medical observation
no answer no answer
gentleton just blocked Stephen Miller in
response
so the problem with this is not John
fetterman himself once again it's
impossible not to feel sad for John
fetterman or anyone else who suffers
from mental illness a lot of us are
eccentric some of us are very eccentric
in a tolerant and compassionate Society
should do its best to help people
suffering from problems like depression
or schizophrenia or whatever
the problem is that a society that
elevates people who are mentally ill is
doomed wouldn't a functional Society
Elevate people to positions of
leadership who are the wisest the
smartest the sanest who had the greatest
degree of foresight and emotional
self-control yes it would
they would not intentionally put people
in positions of authority who were
incompetent they would not allow John
fetterman to write railroad safety
legislation from his bed in the psych
ward that is pardon the description
insane
Biden of course will celebrate this as a
new glass ceiling shattered as if we're
all empowered by being governed by
people who can't think straight
but this is a dead end this road this
way of thinking is destructive for
everyone it's not empowering it's
grotesque
and if we continue we might wind up with
people dressed in Admirals outfits
pretending to be women that could happen
I am honored to serve as the first
female four-star officer of the U.S
Public Health Service commissioned Corps
now that person is obviously mentally
ill but so are the rest of us if we
accept it as normal subscribe to the Fox
News YouTube channel to catch our
nightly opens stories that are changing
the world and changing your life from
Tucker Carlson tonight